with summer just around the corner many
parents are scrambling to find good
summer camps especially as experts say
kids need more interaction after the
pandemic but some say the price tag on
some of these camps is turning them away
it's just too high sally had a meow
spoke to parents and one school looking
to ease that burden
they're not just sitting here
babysitting they're teaching the kids as
well chris barcelo has lived in the
valley since 2007. he finds summer camps
to be crucial in his child's learning it
was a rough couple years for
all the young kids you know not being
able to be around other kids their age
the interaction the social skills social
skills and learning at the same time is
a win for barcelo and mom of two krista
speigner i'm actually a big proponent
for year-round schooling but when it
comes to affordability it can be a
problem for many parents because
everything has gone up the prices
it's very expensive owner of sunset
montessori school victoria martinez says
they are lending a helping hand because
of the grant we were able to stay and
thanks to these grants children are
learning the social skills they lost due
to the pandemic the fact that there
was actually a grant here that all the
children got a scholarship and having
two children
that's been huge for us martinez says
while parents face affordability issues
they too face lack of help we've been
doing summer camps for 11 years
and i've never faced a problem like this
sally jaramillo live local now